but season four of one day at a time so
happy that it found a home here in
canada
first of all tell me how are you doing
during this pandemic are you taking
things one day at a time
sorry about the time that's my line i
say that all the time i love it
uh um yes i definitely one day at a time
it's
when it when it first started uh when we
were first made aware of it in march
i was thinking my god can you imagine if
this goes on for more than three months
and now i'm just kind of like yeah this
has been going on
so it's been a roller coaster it's you
know
of course we all know you go through
every emotion but
that's part of the reason i took dancing
with the stars because i
really needed to do something
to feed my soul how's that going by the
way i'm having so much fun watching
i i would love to send you a video i
have videos of my children
emulating you guys on the dance floor as
you're doing it it's the most amazing
thing
but how are you how are you loving it
because we're loving it
you know i was thinking about that i was
texting with a friend this morning
and we were thinking about you know the
same thing how difficult this whole
uh pandemic has been and i all of a
sudden god
was filled with a bunch of gratitude
that the only thing i'm complaining
about is
how much pain i'm in and
and like girl are you crazy you're 48
years old like that's how i feel every
time i go there and i'm like oh god my
knees my ankles
but what a blessing that that's the only
thing that i'm complaining about right
now
yeah well you keep doing it because we
are loving it and we're so proud of you
and so excited for you it's so great
yeah um okay so let's go to there was a
moment
um when season three was the end of one
day at a time and then thankfully it was
picked up for season four
tell me about the emotional
rollercoaster that must have accompanied
that moment in time what was that like
it was very uh i went through grief and
uh i was really sad and i did a lot of
crying and it would just come out of
nowhere
and i thought that i was over it and and
then all of a sudden we got saved
and it was so surreal and then we got
shut down because of everything
i think this is rita says it all the
time this is just this
show with so much heart this little show
that just will not stop
and the fact that we are re-airing the
show
on cbs that is such a big deal for us
so many eyes on that network and such a
possibility
that this incredible show about an
immigrant family about a cuban american
family
that's universal about family and love
can actually
be on network television that is the
dream
yeah for sure so what was the moment
like when you were all reunited back on
set for season four
tears dances of joy we were shocked we
were all we just sat at the table
like oh my god we're back
and a lot of a lot of happiness you know
there had been almost a year
of us not knowing what was going on oh
was it there was
yeah because when you're on um streaming
you have so much time in between when
you shoot a show on netflix
you take maybe two three months to shoot
it and then
um they show it maybe five months later
you have maybe eight to ten months in
between seasons
wow it's kind of insane and so we had so
much time between seasons i think we'd
gone through every emotion
and once we got there it felt as if we'd
never left
that's the truth oh i love that well
that's a testament to
your crew and everyone there okay so
season four
ray romano is in the premier episode
playing a census taker
who comes to interview your family
brilliant casting we all think it's
brilliant
um what was it like having ray on set
he's great because
you know when you work in a sitcom uh
what they'll do is they'll
rush over the writers and they'll give
you different jokes
or different monologues so you you know
they'll walk up to you and they'll say
okay try this try that
he didn't want to know and that's how he
worked on everybody loves raymond he
would just
improv which was so great because i
didn't know what was coming
and it was hilarious and usually you
know what's coming because they've told
everybody
so that just shows you how brilliant
that guy is and uh
he would just get a scenario and then
just go for it no no what happens is we
have the scenario
but what will happen is that they'll
change a joke right they'll say like
what's a good joke uh
uh what can we do let's try this joke
okay we already did that joke let's try
this joke
he just he he was just free with the
jokes you know and usually they'll let
you know the other cast members
what the new joke is gonna be so you're
not put off uh or start laughing
and he doesn't work like that he just he
he tells the jokes and it's pretty
refreshing and fun and and um
exciting that's amazing i love that so
season three ended with penelope
graduating and getting her degree
and she was single where will we see
penelope's love life in season four and
will she get the happiness that she so
deserves she
will get the happiness and i think
everyone will be pleased to see
who she's getting happiness with
okay more what you can't just
oh weird that was so weird but yes it's
kind of
i was like looking into this green light
and talking to you is like yes
i know it's so strange isn't it so
strange um but
um yes she it's it's so she she gets
happiness that she deserves she really
does it's a good season okay okay so
season
um you know well there is a lot of love
in the air and your son alex has also
found love
so how does penelope feel about her boy
finding a girl
i don't know what i would do with my son
having a girlfriend
he's 10. i don't ah
i think the one that has the problem
with him having a girlfriend
is abuela lydia because that's her guy
um penelope's happy about it you know
she loves when her children are happy
she's she wants them to be social happy
all of that uh lydia that's a different
story
i love that so talk to me about um
you know one going off to college this
family is so tight
what kind of emotions does penelope go
through with her daughter looking to
leave to go to school i would be a mess
i've already i'm already ready i'm like
a disaster
you know right before we started
shooting those episodes we got shut down
uh because of the pandemic we only got
to shoot six episodes and then we did a
seventh that was animation
but we had been talking about that and
that's a big deal
that was part of the journey of the
season for penelope is her children
growing up her children moving away and
then her coming into
her own you know as
you know remembering her womanhood you
know and
and all of that stuff that goes along
with being a woman
yeah this series has really found an
audience and it talks about
you know real issues and it has comedy
and drama and then you know it's just
really the entire package
what has been the secret to the series
success
um if you could pinpoint it oh first of
all
it's tailored after
because it is a reimagining of the
original one day at a time
norman lear's classic television he
revolutionized television with exactly
what you just said
and then we have the brilliant show
runners gloria calderon kellet and mike
royce
and that incredible writers room and and
this cast
and one of the things that's really
fantastic about this show is how
collaborative it is
how so interesting to have to you can go
in there and you can say something
also the fact that this these stories
are being told
by us through us the authenticity and
the specificity
of this family is what makes it so
relatable
so all of those things is what makes
people
gravitate towards the show absolutely
there's some really hilarious and even
embarrassing things discussed on the
show
from time to time was there ever a
moment where you were reading the script
where you were like
what happened it happens a lot it's like
what am i doing yeah but it's so much
fun because i just
love that they okay a perfect example is
i think the second or third season i got
a boyfriend ed quinn
who it basically looks like a greek god
okay
and he walked into the audition and i
said come on
like come on really like i come up to
his like
his waist and gloria goes why not
justina why not
yes i said so yes you see
and so it's like weird things like that
that i've been
that we've been conditioned to believe
that can't happen i mean we see men do
it all the time on tv they're like 80
and they have like a 30 year old
girlfriend
you know or anything so but you know as
women i'm like oh come on this or come
on that and that's what's been so great
about this show it's like yeah why not
justina and i'm like
yeah why not so i got the greek god as a
boyfriend
yes you do yes you do i love it
you know there's some shows where you
see the cast together and you know that
they're really truly
family was that chemistry right off the
top for you guys
was this something that you just you
grew together how did that go
i think we all knew the importance of
this show rita moreno knew
immediately how important it was she you
know
the career she's had the all of the ups
and downs
she knew it right away i certainly knew
it
you know to be the lead of a show at you
know in my mid-40s
with iconic you know rita moreno and
norman lear
and then we had these really wonderful
sweet kids that came in and that were
just great and then of course todd
grinnell and stephen tobolowsky
everybody's kind of a veteran and knew
how
how important this show was and knew
that if we wanted it to go well
we had to give it our all and we just
immediately
had chemistry and immediately loved each
other
i love that and i love just you're right
the message it sends
that you can have this moment at 48 at
whatever age like this is the new world
we're living in
and this is it and i love that yeah
because there was a time when
you know you hit 40 in hollywood and
forget about it and this is not that
it's
it's that's that's the good thing that's
changing in hollywood that
you see a lot of more stories a lot more
stories of women in their 40s
that are not you know looking like their
grandma you know it's like
yeah so uh all
yes it's an important message and it's
beautiful and look at lydia rita
moreno's character
sexy and all that at 88 years old oh
it's possible we can do it we can do
this
absolutely i'm saying yes um
season five i know that you probably
can't say you're just not sure but
what do you know what i do know is that
if people watch
us enough on cbs we'll get a season five
yeah
yeah you know so really that's the focus
for us right now is getting all the eyes
as many eyes as we can on our show those
three mondays because they're doubling
us up
and if that were to happen then we'll be
able to get a fifth season
on a major network and
have many millions of eyes on us that's
amazing
fantastic well i am cheering you on on
dancing with the stars me
and my six-year-old my ten-year-old we
were behind you
canadian love were in your pockets and
uh
thanks for just bringing so much joy
thank you thank you for talking to me
this morning
bye this is great thank you